c'est vraiment le président du bureau et
leur autour de jean michel
[Applaudissements]
jean-michel ça fait longtemps que tu
n'es pas venu mon chéri et il ya plein
de gens qui ont déjà un déjà dire je
suis super content de tout de revenir
c'est vrai que ça me manque je regardais
tous les sorts et c'est pas pareil que
d'autres là évidemment d'atur aussi beau
les gens sont toujours aussi bon alors
et 2 dire il ya énormément de gens qui
m'ont posé dès qu'elles sont mais
pourquoi t'es pas là tu était
embrouillée ex'im c'est tard je voulais
dire aux gens non il n'y a rien du tout
c'est le circuit de tpm paix a toujours
des nouveaux il faut laisser la place
aux nouveaux arrivants qui prennent qui
s'installe qui se trouvent leurs marques
et c deja jeu super content de venir
mais je regardais j'étais content de les
voir et je suis on s'envoyait plein de
sms américian chaque rue et chaque sms
commencer par mon frérot d'amour comment
tu vas avec mathilde envoyant un sms
très très drôle
je le dis aux téléspectateurs c'était
pour pêcher marche là il m'envoyait mon
cyril si tu compte me faire revenir
juste demain pour p&g barça désolé
messieurs par équipes derrière nous
voilà exactement les chéris au galop
mais voilà huile est revenue mais il va
pas tant il va pas il va pas tarder à
repartir
talentueux enfants ont besoin
à l'école
à la pompe une année
oh la la
j'entends jean tangente en foutant
soffiati kelly b novelli
v
la peintre georgia may dans cette
mi-temps les chéris